new story details for god of war
ragnarok have been revealed rockstar is
getting new employees and more
the official playstation store page for
god of war ragnarok has been updated and
it includes what appears to be new story
details the full story description reads
quote kratos and atreus must journey to
each of the nine realms in search of
answers as as guardian forces prepare
for a prophesized battle that will end
the world along the way they will
explore stunning mythical landscapes and
face fearsome enemies in the form of
norse gods and monsters the threat of
ragnarok grows ever closer kratos and
atreus must choose between their own
safety and the safety of the realms
further down the page sony shared a few
more story details as well as a very
brief tease of weapons and abilities god
of war ragnarok releases on november 9th
for ps4 and ps5 so if you still haven't
played god of war 2018 by then then
you're grounded for life and as a gamer
on punishment that means you won't be
able to play gta 6 7 8 and 5 the 20th
anniversary edition i really hope that
one doesn't come true the reason i'm
bringing up gta is because rockstar
currently has a huge list of job
openings at its different studio
locations rockstar new york is looking
for a marketing manager for gta plus the
subscription service that launched for
gta online back in march meanwhile
rockstar san diego is looking for an
associate designer for open world events
and i don't know about you but that
sounds to me like we're getting an open
world rockstar presents table tennis 2.
i'm kidding of course but imagine if i
was right that game has day 1 game pass
written all over it and i'd 100 play
what's interesting is that a bulk of
these job openings surfaced not too long
after rockstar confirmed its slowing red
dead 2 updates in order to focus on the
future of gta the rest of the list
consists of all types of positions from
animation to physics mission design and
more so if you've ever dreamed of
working for the dev this could be your
chance to shoot your shot and speaking
of taking shots daisy and shy guy are
gearing up to make some goals in mario
striker's battle league today nintendo
revealed the game's first free update
and confirmed two more are headed to the
game before the end of 2022 this first
update arrives july 21st and features
daisy a technique type whose super
strike move involves her summoning
flowers and launching the other team
into the air and shy guy and all around
her whose super strike can turn him into
a spinning projectile and that's not all
this free update also features a new
knight themed gear set and the desert
ruins stadium and don't forget straight
is out right now and got a 9 out of 10
from us here at gamespot and you can
play it if you are a playstation plus
extra or premium subscriber so right
when i'm done with this i'm going to go
back to being a cat devonte meowsome
my middle name is marquis so devonte
meow chisholm got it nailed it let's go
you